Japan's own cinema industry has been struggling recently.
But, box-office revenues have been given a boost, thanks to the popularity of anime,...
...the unique Japanese style of hand-drawn animation.
Directed by Makoto Shinkai, "Your Name" has been topping Japan's box-office charts...
...since the release at the end of August.
The Tokyo Film Festival has become an important event for the anime industry.
And one of the genre's most successful directors, Mamoru Hosoda,...
...is being honored this year with a retrospective of his work.
Hosoda says the secret lies in stories that capture the hearts of grown-ups.
Hosoda's feature, "The Boy and the Beast,"...
...was the second highest-earning Japanese film last year.
Making more than 55 million dollars.
And like this year's megahit "Your Name," it proves that the anime experience...
...delivers at the box-office as well as on the big screen.